it's the new year it's white time here's
what we've got for you in the next ten
minutes we head to Las Vegas to take in
the weird and wonderful at the world's
biggest Gadget Show
you've heard of drone racing now we
bring you drone gaming with lasers and
one of the biggest franchises and video
games is back we've got a Resident Evil
7 biohazard in our review hello and
welcome to your very first toy for 2017
before we talk about laser battle drones
we're gonna kick off in Vegas for the
biggest tech trade show of the year Greg
has been at Viera it's hard to believe
but they've been doing this now for 50
years and you wonder what the tech fan
of 1967 would make of what's on display
in 2017 CES this year is dominated by
virtual and augmented reality by
robotics by those home voice-activated
assistants and by merging the smart
worlds of the two places we spend most
time Toyota is just one of the companies
here unveiling concept cars and all of
them have much greater connectivity and
Toyota is very proud at the fact that
this one has artificial intelligence as
well the gap between the home and the
car is closing and you look at Ford's
tie-up with Amazon where you can speak
to your Alexa at home while sitting in
the car it makes your connected home in
your connected car well connected the
industry says all of this makes cars
better and crucially safer as well and
they say this technology is coming soon
the challenges of self-driving cars are
much greater Toyota says but they are
coming eventually now it seems four
years at CES they've been talking about
OLED TVs and this year is no different
but this is the extraordinary
introduction this year from LG
but they call their wallpaper and you
can see why it's so extraordinary hold
my phone up against it just its depth
less than a tenth of an inch the depth
of this screener just hangs on the wall
no frame and they say a completely
immersive experience but if only TVs are
a staple here something that is big this
year are things like this these
voice-activated robots these things that
will make our homes more connectable
with a little almost human face there
they are everywhere here along with ways
to make you feel what you're seeing
through your virtual reality headset
then for all the gadgets that grab the
headlines see as is about the
evolutionary process of all of these
things some of them will never get our
hands on but many we will and many very
soon that's what we'll be looking at in
just a moment the quad copters that let
you all your friends with lasers
but this week has really been all about
sphere the one else has been going on
there
well aside from all those cars and
voice-controlled home hubs the wearables
have been getting plenty of attention at
the world's biggest Gadget Show ever
fans had a pair of jeans that can direct
you to your destination no I haven't
either but should you ever these might
be a good fit excuse the pun they're
linked to your phone and Buzz to tell
you which way to turn there's also a
body system I use to monitor breathing
perspiration and temperature and some
speakers hang around your neck because
who wants headphones anymore right you
might not wear this one but you'll be
keeping it pretty close an
internet-connected walking stick that
can alert a carer if you have a fool now
let's not forget about pet tech here's a
dog collar that claims to track behavior
and tell you when your pooch isn't
feeling well also amongst the offerings
of things you didn't even know you
needed an internet-connected hairbrush
built with sensors and a microphone it
can apparently listen to your hair
letting you monitor the effects of
different haircare routines of course
took around four our games review in
just a few minutes we've got the long
awaited and pretty dark Resident Evil 7
biohazard but before that there's been a
lot of talk around Star Wars in recent
weeks the new movie rogue one became a
box-office hit and then we had the sad
news that Carrie Fisher had died like a
lot of major franchises Star Wars has
always gone big on its merchandising and
its new toy is apparently gonna make
drone gaming the next big thing well
that's what the makers tell me anyway
there's somebody uses for drones as you
see with delivery and inspection of
agriculture and things like that but
then you have the lifestyle application
of drones you've seen recently drone
racing has become extremely popular and
it's just moving very quickly adding
lasers to the drones it just creates a
whole new dimension it's a new element
it means that we can actually interact
we can battle
okay so coming are you gonna play see
I'm gonna play
flying sailor here I need someone to
shoot that I can shoot you my drone can
recognize that it's been shot and it can
just it creates a level of gaming into
the product how much do these drones eat
special collector's box there are 200
pounds in the UK with lasers encoded
with data that you can transfer from one
ship to another I think it sets off a
whole new era of the drone industry it's
not really a toy the product is a
high-tech item oh you got which of the
big tech companies experiments with
drones is interesting you the most right
now
what's pretty impressive what Amazon is
trying to do with drones how they're
using them to efficiently deliver
packaging at a much or product at a much
faster rate
but I'm also very fascinated by a
company out of Germany called Festo
robotics that is incorporating animal
movement into integer owns going back to
commercial drones what do you think
about the hacking risk this is not much
you can do when you hack somebody's
drone it can't do very much it can just
be flown to a different destination so I
don't think that's a major issue what if
it was a drug taxi that was hacked and
you'll have happened there I think
that's I think that's years away before
we see before we see drone taxis
I'm gonna wreck one of these now time
for this week's games review the first
of 2017
Cena's we've got a bit of a theme going
on here guess which game we're gonna
start with is Ross 2017 is said to be
another huge year for video games and
2016 saw some big games as well released
one of which which was Star Wars
Battlefront it came actually over 12
months ago but has had DLC which is
downloadable content released for it
over the last 12 months and the most
recent one came out in line with the
brand new Star Wars film rogue one this
new DLC is set around that and comes
with a brand new game mode called
infiltration mode which sees you start
in space around the planet and end up on
the planet in the jungles and beaches of
scary it is an amazing new add-on to the
game so if you've got Star Wars
Battlefront you had the season pass
should have got this free if you didn't
you can buy it all on its own just so
you can experience rogue one plus there
is a brand new free add-on on the ps4
which sees a VR mission yes if you've
got the PlayStation VR headset you can
now pilot an x-wing again in the rogue
one setting it is one of the most
amazing experiences that I've actually
had in VR so if you've always had a
dream of flying an x-wing this is your
opportunity so Star Wars Battlefront
road 1 is out now
January sees the release of one of the
biggest gaming franchises with the next
installment from Resident Evil this
being Resident Evil 7 biohazard brand
new game loads of new features but also
going back to the roots of some of the
original games so this time you're going
to be playing in first-person mode as a
character named Ethan who is a civilian
which is very different to the normal
characters that you've seen in previous
Resident Evil 7 games you find yourself
searching for your wife and you end up
in this mansion which again is quite
similar to many other Resident Evil
games but this time being in
first-person mode it definitely ups the
scare factor if you're looking for a
classic game horror based but also
first-person shooter and going to give
you a huge amount of playable appeal
Resident Evil 7 biohazard is definitely
the one you should pick up in January
college idiom for the warfare got off to
a bit of a rocky start on its launch in
2016 but it also still made it to
Christmas number one and its first DLC
launches exclusively on PlayStation 4 on
the 31st of January the DLC is entitled
sabotage but the zombies takes you to
the next level so after the first part
in zombies in space land which came with
the original part of the game this is
now rave in the red wood it looks like
it's going to be linked to a previous
map from a previous Call of Duty which
is game quite horrible so it looks like
the character's going to have a whole
load of huge more fun with zombies and
again the four new DLC maps also offer a
great way of getting the multiplayer
action with all the game modes into new
levels and new experience to try and
master
that's it for this week but in case you
didn't know you can watch any of our
swipe episodes on demand and all the
usual places and follow us on Twitter at
Sky News swipe to see what we get up to
throughout the week join us again next
time bye bye
[Music]